out of washington where a 911 style
commission will be established to
investigate last month's assault on the
capitol
house speaker nancy pelosi made the
announcement yesterday in a letter to
colleagues she said the commission
would be independent ed o'keefe is at
the white house for us where president
biden has mostly stayed focused on his
agenda
but ed members of both parties already
say that former president trump is at
least partly responsible for the
violence at the capitol
so what more do we expect this
commission to actually accomplish
well good morning tony look these kinds
of commissions are rare in part because
we don't usually have this kind of
violence but also because
they usually have bipartisan support in
this case speaker pelosi says
that the commission will be based on or
modeled on the commission formed after
the terrorist attacks of september 11th
2001.
that was a bipartisan group that
investigated the circumstances leading
up to those attacks
the recommendations from that panel led
to among other things the creation of
the director of national intelligence
which oversees all intelligence agencies
but one of the potential challenges with
this new commission is that unlike the 9
11 attacks
the capital riot had partisan political
motivations and most members of congress
seem to have already made up their minds
about what led to it but this
also means that at least part of
washington will still be dealing with
the fallout from the capital attacks
and former president donald trump's role
in them as the current president joe
biden tries pushing forward with his own
agenda
at the top of the biden agenda the
pandemic and economic relief
from it he heads to wisconsin tonight
his first official trip
on air force one as president first
official trip west
to sell his nearly two trillion dollar
covert relief plan in a town hall
meeting he's hoping
to convince voters in a state that he
narrowly won to sign on to this
legislation
as republicans continue to criticize the
size and scope of what he calls
the american rescue plan anthony ed
o'keefe
thank you ed